on this episode I come back solo with
thunder
ah
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 216 of the askgaryvee
show a little post fourth of July show
it's weird I'm not even sure the last
time I did an episode where there was
another human being with me in the
office
very much like out of sync and excited
to get back into sync Facebook live our
team is like tripled since we like right
like all these new characters Sydney in
turns back
India's away so Britt you're gonna have
to you ready to play that role all right
so that's good you had a good fourth and
nice you guys
I'm good stop it you're not great
awesome
all right I'm super excited what's been
going on last month all good stuff um
been traveling a lot running vaynermedia
a lot going on obviously a lot of guests
which has been fun but I'd be lying if I
didn't say that I was super excited to
get it kind of a little bit back into
the rhythm of just you and I especially
cuz people really hate the way I
interview people because as one but I
would like to say as one person you
mailed me it was a psychologist my brain
works too fast according to her and
since I already know what the other
person saying I'm not patient enough to
let it come through but I'm not doing a
good enough job projecting that your
guys brains don't work as fast as mine I
was dying when I got that email is like
I think that's the best I'm gonna start
using them like guys I'm sorry my brains
too fast but uh no question I get hyper
when I when the guests are here so I
apologize for all of you that hate when
I interrupt the guests but we don't edit
I step on I really think that's what it
is I feel the pressure of not editing
whereas when I'm on shows and I'm on for
[ __ ] 53 minutes and it becomes a 27
minute podcast it's easy all my rambling
or whatever they didn't like they get to
edit these guests ramble and they're
promoting and that's not bringing you
any values so you're mad at me from
trying to make a show good for you
do you agree all right of course another
let's say you have to agree I saw that
too you see I know that I know that
because you know me but do you see the
bus episode of dailyvee they're like
they're like oh Gary's not that funny
everybody has to laugh I'm like
dude I'm super funny no there was no
that's million India I'm not will have
to come up we're own thing yeah alright
let's do this earth Walker asks do you
have a [ __ ] list people organizations
you won't work with for whatever reason
that's an interesting question you know
and actually you know one thing I
promised myself on my comeback trail
here in episode 16 is I'm gonna answer
these questions not just you know kind
of literally black and white but I'm
gonna try to really challenge myself I
think the golden eras of this show was
when I could answer the question but
then also know how to bring value to the
whole audience and I right off the bat
came in hot I'm excited which is I don't
and now let's talk about it I truly
believe that anybody who has a [ __ ] list
has a vulnerability because when you're
using negativity to drive your success I
think that's a problem to me spending
any energy and time with a list of
people that I don't want to do business
with or put out a business or negative
or like people that got me and I'm gonna
get them back I think is insane it's
stunning to me looking back my 20 year
career there was a guy that I went to a
wine tasting of went to the wine tasting
in New York City at the Hilton the Wine
Spectator national wine tasting all the
best wineries are there I came in and I
come and I go to a winery and they have
a great Shiraz Australian wines are
getting super like you know hot and I'm
like selling a lot of them more than
anybody in the country and I come in
like I love to taste wine thinking this
guy is gonna react really well because
we've sold a ton of it he goes into a
curse slating I'm a piece of crap I
never had this happen to me in life like
just drilled me you're you're the devil
of the industry I hate you like nasty
nasty nasty stuff um and it was because
I was selling his wine at the most
aggressive price in the country and he
thought I was killing his brand
meanwhile there were thirty other stores
selling it for that price but he hadn't
been on top of technology yet and didn't
know there was a site called wine
searcher that allowed me to see every
price on the internet and I was just
matching the best price in the country
but because I was the biggest guy when I
emailed it and promoted it all the other
stores that were selling it for more
called and complained he did no homework
he was immature he was
very hot at the time so he had the
audacity and ego needless to say the
Australian wines got less hot over next
five years and then that coincided with
Wine Library TV explosion and then this
guy who said I was the devil of the
industry and the worst piece of crap at
a loser kid was never gonna amount to
anything
emailed me five years later begging for
me to be on the show for exposure of his
wine and with no hesitation I said yes I
believe being the bigger man I believe
not holding grudges I believe that one
of the reasons I'm successful in life
let alone business is I don't allow
poison or negativity to be stored within
my confines and I think it's a very big
thing I've been talking a lot more about
optimism and positivity being a real
factor I'm starting to get a little more
Zen in my older age and I believe that I
believe that if you have a [ __ ] list if
you have a list if you hold a grudge
you're coming at your own expense that
you're not doing everything do I forget
know but it's just context it doesn't
mean I'm going to get you with it it
just means I have to navigate around it
that's a very big difference I don't
want to stick it to you I just need to
navigate around your truth and there
might be some negativity there and I
want to get around it I don't want to
walk into your cancer over and over and
get punch in the face they either um so
I would highly recommend for all of you
if I can do anything with this episode
if this becomes the moment in your life
where you stop thinking having a [ __ ]
list and by the way so many people my
family loved that they loved the grudge
list Eastern European old-school like
you know we're going to get them we're
going to stick it to them in the end you
know I think the positivity in the
winning I think nothing nothing sticks
it to anybody better than results you
know instead of instead of tearing them
down just get so goddamn big that that's
the ultimate I got you back and that
comes to positivity how are they liking
it in facebook what are you talking
about you just looked at it in one
second I've only seen the video I know
how Facebook live looks alright I
thought you were more mesmerised by the
say hello you haven't even set up you
said hello yet to ours the new intern on
ask how do you spell it
AR is my hair's not Harris and not
Horace like Horace Grant you
son-of-a-bitch that miserable Hannibal's
it's being pols Derrick Rose and Jay
Noah who's gonna be my favorite Nick
because that's just like the way he
plays I tweeted like Noah is literally
my least favorite player which means
he's going to be my favorite player
nowadays on my team always Caleb asks
would you work a nine-to-five for all of
2017 if it meant you would own the New
York Jets on January 1st of 2018 yes yes
I mean and and you know and then now
trying to challenge myself to make these
good questions you know I'll take it
here anybody who's not willing to do
something that they hate so much in the
short term to have what they love so
much in the long term are is usually the
blueprint of a person that is normally
not winning one of the biggest
separations between me and a lot of
people watching this and other people
that are successful in your life if
you're not or vice versa you the
successful person and the people that
are think you're lucky or curious to why
you're winning is that most winners tend
to have much more patience than their
contemporaries I don't need anything now
and most of people do most people are
such consumers in the u.s. world they
want stuff they want the new iPad they
want the new jeans they want the new
kicks
they want the vacation they you know
they want stuff and with social media
where everybody's PR in their best life
and showing them the new car and then
and I mean this weekend everybody showed
you the best barbecue that they've ever
been to right it makes people have FOMO
and really aspire to more and I'm kind
of the other way like I've just never
wanted those kind of goals I'm not
affected but I'm happy for other
people's glory not not asking why I
don't have that or compare myself to
that I'm in my own zone and I'm very
very very patient so I would eat crap
how about this I would work a
nine-to-five for the next ten years if
you told me I own the New York Jets on
the next day after that how about that
115
20 I would work every day nine-to-five
or next 20 years if he told me at 61
years old I own the New York Jets 30 I
would work every single day for
nine-to-five for a corporation for next
30 years
tonio Jets what happened since now it's
how it works but I would I would cuz by
the way you know how much hustle I would
do from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
like 9:00 to 5:00 is cake that's a habit
I mean you guys know that that's a half
a day it's a half a day that's like
writing I be like that's the other part
I don't think people understand I
literally work 18 hours a day 15 hours a
day like like working about 9:00 to 5:00
like like that would be amazing
like I play basketball every morning and
work out and work and then work and then
hang out with my family - that would be
insane 40 years George asks I'm curious
to see where granny bee is headed seems
to be getting a lot of traction are you
gonna make it a thing for all of you
that missed grandma V over the I guess
Wednesday and Thursday of last week
there was a filter on snapchat i went
into character called grandma v granny v
i converted it to granny because just
better uh and you know she was just
basically was really funny about it was
she was just basically saying the same
things i say except it's funny i think
of myself as an old soul and just makes
more sense basically she I just made
videos on snapchat where she said in my
day and then basically said the things I
believe in there was a lot of fun and
boy did it catch fire people really
passionate about it unfortunately the
the granny filter is gone now and I
don't know if they're bringing it back
so I don't know where it's going
I guess we could design it I guess
Angela could draw it and we could put it
over my head at times I do think I
should do a granny B episode of the
askgaryvee show
I'm super willing to do it if Andrews
willing to draw it and impose if you
guys can figure it out team I will do a
whole episode in costume one little fun
facts to find you forget these edits
sometimes even still so do not miss this
one this is not the first time I went
into character way back in the day
touring Wine Library TV there was a
character called sir Gary Vaynerchuk
which was the classic
more serious wine reviewers the font
given 30 seconds right now the key to
everything is this Gary isn't hungry and
it is now the Friday show now obviously
he could not do this on Monday because
it was raining and it was a Monday and
how could you possibly do a Friday show
on Friday so I threw the couch out the
window and I've jumped in and taken over
the show today he's not here call it a
coup d'etat for you so I've been known
to do this before and it has inspired me
to consider going into character on
snapchat filters more often because I
think it's interesting content I think I
can pull it off and I think it's a
blueprint for a lot of you I think a lot
of you that are struggling that are
comedians or improv actors or have that
DNA they're trying to figure out what to
do on snapchat I do think the filters
and all these characters is an
incredible storytelling opportunity
Branden asks where are the reviews for
vaynermedia and Glassdoor so bad so this
one's tough for me um I you know there's
a lot of reasons why our reviews on last
door for vaynermedia or not as good as
they should be or the reality of our
culture I think first of all I think it
has a lot to do with many different
things first of all um nonnamous
websites right so you look at secret and
whisper an anonymous you're going to get
people that are willing to go to
extremes when nobody can figure out who
that person is so anonymous leads to it
too we've gone from 30 to 650 people in
four years there's a lot of pain in that
and a lot of people that our employees
struggle with the constant change in the
different decision making I move very
quickly and a lot of times I don't do
the greatest job explaining my actions
to everybody and I think that creates
you know I think a lot of movement a lot
of structural changes creates a lot of
angst for people that are more
comfortable and it's easy for the
entrepreneur it's harder for the
employees three I think cynicism is
unfortunately quite powerful so I think
that um I think that uh that's the case
I think some of the early ones back in
2011 are just I think I did a bad job I
wasn't really the active CEO a veiner
and I don't think we micro managed our
youngest talent so I feel good I mean I
feel bad but good about the one 7-eleven
the last 15 of them and I read them all
50 times a month are coming from
employees that I don't think we saw the
world the same way I mean you know I
don't know what people expect from
former employees but if they're fired or
if they quit they obviously don't feel
great about the business and that's okay
I mean I think you go look at any I
think Yelp and Glassdoor and all these
anonymous sites struggle because what
you don't have is I'm not going to do
what most companies do which try to
incentivize their employees to leave
positive reviews to offset the negative
reviews that's not going to happen I I
use them as feedback loops even though
we try here but like these are people
that you know are not happy with the way
we're doing things but I think the
problem is the silent majority it's kind
of like the Britain exit you know I have
so many friends who are like I wish I
bought it I mean you had a chance but
you didn't I think I think it's politics
right there's a lot of people that don't
talk about their views on you know you
hear you know you look in the internet
you see the loud minorities dictate a
narrative and then the punchline is
mainly I think everything starts from
the top which is I actually like having
a bad review on Glassdoor I think that
any individual that takes an anonymous
website of former employees and people
say their current employees that are
former I had somebody who I did a nice
thing for call me and say look I just
want to know something when I left a bad
this was somebody I did something nice
for a year after they were fired they
called me because they felt guilty and
said I left a really nasty review
because I felt that was unfair I was
super mature and I also left it as a
current employee because I thought that
would hurt you more so like you know I
think that anybody who would stay out of
a company any company looking at Vayner
or what-have-you
because of glassed or any other
anonymous site as the proxy to what's
actually happening there is exactly the
kind of people that I want to keep out
it's people that are playing checkers
versus chess there so I don't to say
basic mind me because I don't want to
razz but like I don't understand how
somebody wouldn't understand that this
is anonymous site of people that are at
least happy about something so I think
there's a lot of reasons we have a tough
review there they don't make me happy
I'm really upset when people are unhappy
with things but I'll be honest with you
when you're the CEO of a company that
has gone through thousands of employee
last four years I've had a lot more
conversations one-on-one of somebody
saying that they're mad at me or they
don't like things and they're saying it
to my face that hurts even kind of more
because I respect them so much for going
that route and I want to fix it for them
you know I'm in the firefighting
business like everything is always hard
there's always problems but I'm pretty
confident about what's actually
happening here I think that shows in its
results I think when you look at the
macro turnover rates here voluntary
turnover is what I look at we're
crushing the market people aren't
leaving because they want you know
because they don't like it here and so
there's always going to be a percentage
of people that don't like certain things
that I don't think I'm perfect or this
company is perfect especially because
we're always making different changes
but I know that no CEO organization has
more intent to have people talk to us
about it some people I look at my own
father some people keep things inside
and we'll never share it and so I can't
fix what I don't know and then when it
doesn't work out whether on their choice
or our choice because they kept that
poison in a lot of those same people
can't communicate in real life but love
to go on anonymous site and and get that
poison out and to be frank with you I
actually love Glassdoor for a helping me
not allow people to come in that have
low EQ and are looking at it on a basic
level and be I'm happy that those people
are able to get their poison of what
they feel about me or vaynermedia out of
their body and move on just like I
talked about in the beginning I hope it
helps and I hope I hope with that out
they can take a step back look at the
big picture maybe reach out to me and
continue our relationship I'm very proud
of my relationship with a lot of former
employees that left on bad terms and I
will continue to do that forever because
I care about my legacy because I'm more
selfish about that than the money and
things that nature and it's and by the
way you know as somebody who's very
close to the business I would say I'm
I'm 70% sure of the exact person that
leaves every review and there's a lot of
never I'm never confused you know like
it just makes sense like sometimes
things don't go well in our people
relationships and things that nature and
so is what it is it's a it's a it's a
challenge because I care so much but if
you're watching this and you're
currently at Manor or you used to be a
veiner
and you still have negativity and you
I'm super available I'm Gary up
Media I've always been available I'll
always be available and I think that
that to me is much more interesting you
know I'm not worried about the
perception
Glassdoor is 2.6 rating on vaynermedia
isn't stopping the thousand applications
a week we're getting or the growth of my
company I care way more about the 20
people that are upset with me or this
I'm here to fix it forever if there's
actually something to fix and even if
there's not yeah
feel good about that answer is going to
be Tony says going to be deep here how
do you deal with people who take
advantage of you you give never take
does it get lonely yeah I mean I think
what I tend to do and I'm telling a lot
of these things together one of the
reasons I don't try to manipulate
Glassdoor like all my friends companies
do is it helps you actually get the
truth I think one of the things that's
great about meritocracy open-ended not
holding grudges is you get to see truths
one of the things that I think I've done
quite well and that I highly recommend
to a lot of you is not to manipulate
situations so by letting things play out
you get hurt but because I'm so
emotionally stronger I'd like to think I
am it gives me data I when people hurt
me or take me for granted or don't see
the bigger picture I don't look at that
as a negative
I look at as a data point it allows me
to decide what opportunities I want to
give that person if I'm in control do I
want to do things with that person if
I'm not in control do I give that person
opportunities because I am in control in
Reverse if I think that they're being
very appreciative or they see the big
picture so one of the things that I
think is quite important is not
manipulating one's truth and so to me
somebody taking advantage of me is very
common a I'm most comfortable in being
taken advantage of because I like the
leverage of it so that's a whole weird
thing of my own mishegoss which is
craziness and yet ish I think you know
so like I've got my own kind of thing I
love giving I I create environment
I'm self-aware enough to know that I
create a lot of the beds that I make
that lead to people taking advantage of
me because I don't create boundaries of
my giving early on and the behavior
becomes it's like just you know like
anything else right like
rich kid by like by eating too much by
anything discipline if you're not
praying parameters so I feel like I make
the bed to do that
thus I can't be a hypocrite and be upset
about it the reason I like it is I think
I went twice won it just feels nice I
don't mind it I can I'm good
I'm good so I'm not scared by people
doing negative things to me because I'm
globally good emotionally forever
- it's just data I just love watching
people navigate in a blank space if you
don't make too many rules if you don't
have too much process if you do run your
company quickly if you do all those
things you actually get to see what
people actually do in real life
circumstances not the manipulated rules
and structures and processes that you
create that inevitably slow you down
make you too big to change and lead to
your demise in the game of
entrepreneurship so I'm very calculated
and comfortable CC calculated and
comfortable in the way I build
businesses and very honestly whether you
like it or not whether I like it or not
the results have spoken for themselves I
win and I think that when I look at
other people playing similar games they
win - and so you know how do I feel
about it I feel like I'm thankful that
I'm in an emotional place that allows me
to be able to eat it for breakfast and I
think any of you that are emotionally
capable to be taken advantage of should
it's called leverage
yeah good show I feel like I feel like
that was a good strategy going into the
show trying to level them up right you
liked it do you rock
ot Devon Harris horse-cars phenomenal
awesome question of the day um push in
the day tell me about your most positive
work experience I think we always talk
about what's wrong than that I'm gonna
start really like right tell me like why
why can't we read the comments and all
get excited learn from that we can learn
from the positive like I'm just tired of
cynicism and negativity the political
climate like the world climate like like
just you know what there's so much good
going on you know
so many of you had over the last 72
hours like there's so much good to be
thankful for tell me about your most
positive work experience in detail tag
people that did nice things for you
Chauncey Billups a basketball player
just wrote an article and players
Tribune about and gave naps to Terrell
Brannan it was awesome it was awesome to
see an athlete be like this guy put me
on when he got injured you never hear
that you always hear like the
documentary were like and the star
player got injured and even though he
was trying to suppress the kid the kid
got his chance and one Sue's he put me
on in the right way like we need to be
pushing optimism and positivity some
more because that's really what works so
tell me about your in detail tag the
person that deserves the love about your
most positive work experience you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
you